Johnny Carson that's who I grew up
watching the great Johnny Carson uh
Tonight Show host and uh you have the
this great story about playing poker
with Johnny Carson which was I guess a
it's a famous poker game that I've heard
about but you were invited to be in that
yeah and I hadn't met Johnny Carson at
that point it was a it was like a really
really really wealthy poker game you
know everyone was in a billionaire kind
of poker game you know it was Carl
Reiner and Neil Simon and Chevy Chase
and Steve Martin and Johnny Carson Dan
Melnick famous agent and I'm probably
leaving out another oh and and well
anyway and so they were all you know and
I said to Steve why can't these Steve
said why don't you come there's someone
wasn't showing up and I said oh Barry
Diller that's another billionaire and I
said well I can't you know I'm this is
out of my league Steve I can't he said
no no no no no no no the most that
anyone has ever lost is six hundred
dollars and you could win six hundred
dollars who's to say so there's sort of
like a nice yeah that's the most so I go
there I'm very nervous and it's every
you know every Idol I've ever had are
you doing Johnny Carson my God is there
and I sit down and we start playing and
so I keep saying okay yeah I could win
600 that's right within about five
minutes I'm down eighteen hundred
dollars and
and I kept thinking well this is a
disaster what am I going to do and so I
I kept folding I get four aces full
because I thought if I just lost the
ante I would be down you know 1200 I
could survive It Anyway there was a
dinner in the middle of it and I was
very nervous and I'm sitting beside
Johnny Carson and between and Steve
Martin and Steve said something funny
and I went like this
and my mouth was filled with mashed
potatoes and I had the Sensation that
mashed potatoes had flown out of my
mouth and landed somewhere but I didn't
know where and I'm suddenly looking
around
and I seen it's on Johnny's hand
the biggest guy in Show Business the
biggest guy in show business has my
mashed potatoes in his hand then I
looked over uh to say something and then
I looked back and it was gone so I just
assumed he ate it
I mean just because you're a legend yeah
you don't you still get hungry yeah yeah
the person had a lizard tongue oh that
was unbelievable he loves taters it
wasn't see I didn't know then that he
had people preach you his food and I
know
he was a preacher yeah now you've been
uh you've been given a great honor in
your home nation of Canada they've
they've made a stamp it's a stamp it
does with with your face on it not just
once but several times that was disgust
I'm I'm horrified no I'm not I'm I'm
happy for you I think that it's hard for
me to imagine your face is on a stamp
that usually happens when someone has
passed on well I also have a three
dollar coin in Canada the Marty
the Marty well that's what I call it
it's a three dollar coin yeah if you're
like the king of Canada I really am in a
way we have I think we have the let's
see the stamp there's the stamp
[Applause]
they gave one to Jim Carrey right Mike
Myers and to uh a brilliant Canadian
comedian named oliviera gimo ah yeah uh
took the energy down
I can't not mention everybody yeah you
got to mention them all that's Canadian
as well